>>Teacher: You had so much
to offer yesterday. You okay?
>>Aiden: I'm tired.
>>Teacher: So what's going on?
>>Dr Darling-Hammond: Strong
relationships are
central to the learning process.
>>Dr Darling-Hammond: What the science of
learning and development tells us is
that we need to create learning
environments, which allow for strong,
long-term relationships for
children to become attached to school
and to the adults and
other children in it.
>>Dr Cantor: When children have
experiences of closeness and consistency
and trust, oxytocin is released.
And oxytocin has many, many positive
effects on the development of the brain.
So when we think about a
relationship, we're not just talking
about being nice to a child.
We're talking about a child
having an experience of attunement
and trust strong enough to
release the hormone oxytocin.
>>Falon: Good morning, Ariella!
How are you doing today?
>>Falon: The purpose of the morning
greeting is to connect with them
and to just make sure that
I'm seeing them as humans.
Like I'm making that relationship
with them, making that bond.
>>Catherine: I prioritize
relationship building, because getting
to know them is the best
part of the job.
>>Salma: When I come in in the
morning, we usually talk about things
that are happening in our community.
>>Catherine: We're trying
to build caring and respect.
>>Salma: Teacher is trying to understand
who I am, and my values as a person.
>>Kirsten: When I have a
free 45 minutes or an hour,
I think to myself I could sit down
and catch up on grading, or I could go
and make connections, whether it's
a smile, or a joke, or a reminder,
it validates their presence
in the building.
>>Lindsey: Rock it out in the art room.
>>Lindsey: It starts from so much
honest and transparency with kids.
It's really easy to strive
to be this like idealized,
always ready to go, elementary
school teacher.
And that's not real,
and that's not human.
>>Lindsey: When people start talking
about other things while I'm still
giving direction, it feels frustrating
for me, and I have to take a breath.
[deep breath]
>>Lindsey: My students connect most with
me when they see that I also struggle,
and I also have challenges.
It takes a lot of vulnerability
on my part.
>>Bobby: When that student
knows that you care about them,
when they know that you're a
human, their academic performance
in your class is going to be better.
>>Cassidy: If I'm comfortable
around them then I'm more confident
around them, and it's easier to
ask questions and things like that.
>>Teacher: So when you're
looking at this graph,
what is it that you think happened?
>>Aiden: Some teachers I don't
always get along with the best.
So at times, I'm like, "I can't do
it!" So I'm just not going to do it.
But when I like the teacher,
I want to do their work.
And I'll be like, "I can learn this."
>>Teacher: You all have
done outstanding work.
>>Lindsey: Emotion and learning
are completely connected.
>>Teacher: Very good!
>>Lindsey: If you're in a positive
emotional space, if you feel good
about yourself, your teacher.
That actually opens up the
opportunity for more learning.
>>Teacher: Good to see you.
>>Girl: Today, uhm.